there is somebody that tesla has sued
for stealing their self-driving car data
the same company that is accused of
having people that bring that technology
to them x punk
just got a billion and a half dollars on
the new york stock exchange
in an ipo and i'm like these guys are
stealing technology and that billion and
a half dollars doesn't go to the company
it goes to the pboc
the people's bank of china we still
think of risk as digital risk we still
think of risk in the old days of did i
lock my front door
unfortunately what tends to happen is
when we bring people inside a company we
automatically assume that they're good
people
we've forgotten this whole problem about
insider trading about insider situations
who has to know needs known should know
right those are the only people that
need to know
is data security and data being the oil
of the 21st century the thing that
drives artificial intelligence and big
data
we're spending 800 billion dollars a
year on defense and we ought to be
spending it on protecting
the data of our citizens
[Music]
welcome to generally speaking today we
have chris roberts and we're gonna talk
about
i don't know hacking and cyber and
i don't know chris you're gonna have to
tell me what all we're gonna talk about
but i'm really excited about this
conversation
um and to hear what you have to say so
thanks for coming on general speaking
looking forward to the discussion yeah i
appreciate it and absolutely honored to
be able to hang but hang out with you
again and just you know just basically
shoot the [ __ ] for a while be fun
absolutely that's what this all is all
about is shooting the [ __ ]
um so uh so chris tell us a little bit
about yourself
and um and uh and what you do
yeah so uh obviously um
with the funny accent be based over in
the us for about the last 20 or so years
came over i can tell that it is it's
definitely an american accent
it stays civilized it's gotten worse
over the years i go back
i go back to uh to the uk and everybody
sounds funny there
so it takes me about a week to get the
ear back in and i'm good then i go up to
see family up in scotland and all hell
breaks loose because it's like a week
later
i come back over here and nobody can
understand me for a few weeks
okay so i got to ask you do you know rab
nesbitt
yeah so so so my buddy
in in pilot training was from scotland
and um and he he introduced me to rob
nesbit
now rabb i could never understand what
the hell he said
but he was absolutely hilarious
yeah it's um billy connolly was like
from the it's like the early days of
billy connolly
when he was just pure glaswegian and you
didn't understand anything and it just
went on like that you're like what the
hell's going on
and it's like that you come back here
and then people over here are like
slow down speak american place
but it's fun it's good when you get
stopped by the police or like when the
agencies pull you over or something like
that
you just go into her it's like i say i
do apologize i'm ever so sorry
okay you're gonna have to teach me how
to do that i'm sure that that would get
me out of some scrapes
oh it's useful at speeding tickets
across utah when we're driving italy
defcon with like a whole bunch of
alcohol a bunch of weapons and
everything else in the back of the car
i do i'm oh i'm only allowed to do 70
here i'm ever so sorry i do apologize
that um okay you got to invite me on one
of these trips because it sounds
sounds like the people that you hang out
with there's a lot different
than the people i hang out with yeah we
we get the rough ones it's kind of fun
it's so what what ends up happening is
everybody from like
jsoc socom like 10th roof and everybody
else the ones that are the crazy geekish
ones end up back in our industry
so that same kind of rebellious crazy
mentality
comes into it and then we also get the
ones that have come out of like anywhere
in virginia the farm or anywhere like
that
where they had all the constraints on
and all of a sudden they realized in the
commercial world it's not quite so bad
they're not going to get yelled at as
much
and then all hell breaks loose and it's
just total amount of fun
and they're great amazing people to work
with and quite honestly their family on
the civilian side is absolutely
fantastic
it's like uh it's like the the the guys
coming out of the air and gals coming
out of the air force academy when
they're
made second lieutenants is like ah we're
free
those are the ones you have to watch out
for yeah
yeah it's kind of cute to see and then
all of us yeah it's kind of fun it
really is
um i love the security world i mean
there's there's a ton that's driven nuts
there's a ton that we've got to fix in
it
but there is a lot of camaraderie um and
again because i think so many folks have
come out of former.mill.gov world that
there's just that no [ __ ] let's just
get it done mentality
and it's fantastic so what do you what
do you do now
uh all sorts of things i try not to
annoy a couple of the agencies i do my
best to get up the nose to the fbi on a
regular basis which is kind of a fun
sideline that's not hard to do
no it isn't they're kind of fun to wind
up um
a lot of it's so i kind of split my time
i do the civilized stuff so the virtual
cso work
the consulting side of the work i sit
down i work with organizations
everything from like artificial
intelligence
through to microbiology nanotech biotech
and
just normal like deception technology
and and all that side of the world i
have a ton of work i do on the research
side of the world as well so
we're looking at where the future of
technology is going and going okay
what's good what's bad what's ugly
what do we need to help industries
understand how do they understand how to
do it a few other things
um and then i still get involved in like
pen testing and assessments we actually
just went up against a couple of the
state's voting systems
in the last couple of weeks and to the
credits of the states
they're listening which is absolutely
fantastic it's really nice to see that
they're actually stepping up and going
help us understand so
i get involved in that stuff every now
and again and i do a lot of talking and
i do a lot of lecturing and helping
so on that i mean that's really
interesting so tell me what what what's
your assessment of where the states are
at
uh right now uh you know kind of
generally speaking because i'm sure you
got good and you got bad and
totally uh what's the average look like
i think the states themselves
are aware of the problems they're aware
of the issues they obviously realize
that this one's going to be
really heavily scrutinized ones the
biggest frustration
is still the the issues with the actual
voting systems themselves and
unfortunately that falls at the feet of
really three or four vendors and those
vendors have been told for numerous
years that there are issues challenges
problems whatever you want to call it
and they spend more money on lawyers
defending their position
and putting money into the into the um
the hands of dc
in lobbying efforts they do it actually
fixing a lot of the problems and that's
that's pretty frustrating but
unfortunately it's pretty normal for a
lot of the industries so i mean that's
i mean that's generally speaking across
the board what i see
is you know a more of an effort
to um reduce the
the litigation surrounding an event
rather than spending time to fix the
problem
so you know what would be
you know if you you're king for a day or
in the case of
the united states you're president for a
day and you could say
hey this is these are some things that i
would do in the united states to fix
this problem what are what are some
things that you might
recommend at the policy level to get at
some of these issues
i think a couple of things that's a
really good question a couple of things
um
i would definitely consolidate a lot of
the audit and compliance reporting
i mean i feel a lot of pity for so many
people in this industry because they're
sitting there and they are like okay
i've got to do my quarterly pci i've got
to do my hipaa
my phone by the way every one of the
darn states has got its own flipping pii
stuff
i consolidate the hell out of that we'd
have one set of reporting constraints
and it wouldn't be a tick box and a
check box thing i think there would
definitely be a
it's back to the golden rule you know do
by others as you want to do by yourself
and i think it's like okay what's the
right
thing to do so that'd be one thing
definitely there would be a
whole lot of communication and
collaboration involvements
one of the biggest issues in this in the
industry and you've probably seen this
from coming out from the military side
to the civilian side
in the military if you screw up the
chances are you're going to put your
hand up and go hey i screwed up
everybody around me learned from my
problem because otherwise more people
will die
end of discussion in the civilian world
we don't do that
i apologize there's noise they're
drilling somewhere um oh i thought i
thought there was a gun fight going on
no otherwise you'd see me or carjacking
yeah we'd be under that table with um
wait we'd be firing back let's put it
that way
um they're uh in the civilian world
there's much more of a mentality of
hunkering down
putting the lawyers up and not telling
people around you what's going on and
what's wrong what the problems are we
don't learn from each other's mistakes
as effectively
so i changed that completely we'd remove
a lot of the litigious
honestly we probably put most of the
lawyers in the field and bomb them but
tommy's separate discussion we don't
need lawyers
no we need there's a couple there's some
good ones yeah
um there's some good ones so we'll keep
a couple the rest of them have to go
into a field yeah pretty much yeah they
can become yeah they
they they can become spectators um
that would be part of it and then
honestly a lot of the industry i i would
you know especially in the security
industry i would do a couple of
different things we'd have a much more
robust apprenticeship thing
the ability to move people into this
industry much more effectively again you
take the military
we work you in we run you through a boot
camp we figure out what your mental
level is whether you're going to
basically be cannon fodder
or whether you're going to do you know
anything else along those lines we're
going to figure that out more
effectively and we will work with you we
will train you more effectively so
that pipeline in we take most of the
marketing teams and probably shoot them
as well to be perfectly honest because
again it's
i get it so marketing marketing and
lawyers they're out
oh yeah i think they're done as far as
i'm concerned because again if you think
about it
our job in industry our job in security
we have one job
it's the same as military is to protect
that's it
nothing else there's no other job we
need to do is simply protect people
but we don't do that we spend so much
time justifying our artificial
intelligence and it's better than
everybody else's
and there's 10 other companies waiting
outside your door to tell you that
they're better than the person before
them and it's
any company is just confused well heck
by who we are what we are and what we're
doing
simplify the hell out of that to be
perfectly honest um so yeah
there'd be a few changes coming down the
line the um
so one of the things that um that i've
seen
um you know and talking to industry from
my perspective
is this idea and you brought it up
of um sanctuary
and um and so the the way that i
became more aware of um
the problem was you know from a
briefing that was put together by one of
the top five audit firms that i
was able to look at where all the data
was sanitized
but in this briefing was a um
was a number of vignettes of
targeted attacks you know they called
them
you know little c cyber economic
i call them or big c cyber economic i
call them little c
cyber big e economic because the real
attack was economic cyber was an enabler
for the issue and um
so what what i what i came to understand
is
just exactly what you're saying these
companies have these problems they have
these attacks
and then they hide it and they hide it
for for a number of reasons
and i almost want to turn that on its
head and say okay if we're going to
if we're going to create the sanctuary
it ought to come with both
carrots and sticks in other words the
carrots are
if you if you fess up
we're going to give you a tax benefit
some kind of and a
and a and a immunity benefit
but if you don't then we find out
you know you're gonna get you're gonna
get not only gonna get slammed in taxes
or penalties you're going to um
potentially have
you know prosecutorial issues going on
and i think that would provide
kind of the the the openness and
transparency we have a thing in the
in in military aviation actually in
in all aviation united states called a
hazardous air traffic report
and so if you have a if you have a
traffic violation
in the air not not good it's not good at
a traffic violation in the air but if
you have one
and as soon as you land
you as a pilot file a hatter has us air
traffic report
then you're basically given immunity and
the whole idea
is to promote aviation safety
you know so i i feel like that
your point is let's don't
you know let's create an environment
where
we are being as open and transparent as
we can about the problem
because the whole thing the whole idea
is to fix the problem
not to protect the company from being
sued not because ultimately
and this is where i think the chinese
communist party has us over the barrel
they look at the entire system and says
we want to protect and say we want to
protect the system
and in our in our in our society
each company is in essence their own
chinese communist party
and that's the only thing they care
about well and that's huge because again
think about i mean
you hit the nail on the head i land
anything i land a plane if there's an
issue
it's reported it's distributed the
planes behind me the systems behind me
the architectures behind me
learn very very rapidly as to what's
going on
now we have the isakas and we have the
infra guards and everything else but
just the time it takes to go from point
a to point b
and dissemination of that intonation and
the intelligence behind it
it's just too slow it's way too slow so
as an adversary
i break into you using an attack vector
i don't have to change my tactics
because i know i can take out the next
10 15 companies because nobody's talking
to each other
and i also know again you know let's go
back to military stuff our perfect
example is
wouldn't it be nice to have known really
early on that our
f-35 plans were not exactly in our hands
when we thought they were in our hands
wouldn't it be nice to have known to be
able to course correct to adjust to
understand
and all of the other criteria there
rather than finding out
an exponential amount of time later and
realizing that there's very little we
could have done about it
things like that are huge but again with
to your point it's it's we are you know
i
this country is amazing and it's been
very very nice to me but it's a cluster
of 50 little countries inside one
country and it's like good grief you
we're all batting for the same freaking
team
let's try to all work more effectively
together
so you know just a f-35
um story that you mentioned you know in
your opinion
why wasn't that data encrypted
and and and so because i i i have a hard
time
you know resolving in my mind why any
company would take
you know its crown jewels and that would
you know
because what they do is they they try to
fire walls and
and and this and that but then the data
itself is not encrypted can
can you just speak to that as a security
professional why absolutely
because again what will happen is so
i'll come into your organization and you
have the crown jewels and i'm like hey i
can get something like oh we have
compensating controls
our legal team and our audit team have
said because
because we have to use that data all the
time and because
unfortunately there's still this fallacy
that encrypting data is still complex
and there's
so many ways to do it effectively it's
just ridiculous these days and there's
so many ways even if you
cannot encrypt it there's so many
effective ways to understand that
somebody's
inside your environment if you just take
the time to do it
but people don't or people rely on
compensating controls
or unfortunately so many companies still
think
that they're not going to be breached
and let's face it
everything is attackable everything is
everything we can get into everything
it's the big thing at this point is like
knowing when and knowing what to do
about it
so companies don't think that way
companies think i've closed the front
door we're in good shape
yeah so you know you know when i think
about security
you know the data model is what i focus
on
it you know and fundamentally the data
model hasn't changed
from the very beginning it is it is
about you know how you
you how you treat the data if you can
just
download as much as you want unencrypted
then you essentially are inviting you
know
problems and so encryption is so
important
in in and we don't as even in the
military
you know we we secure data in transport
a lot of the times
but we don't secure it once it gets to
its destination we're like oh we unlock
it we unencrypt it and
and to your point it's all about
convenience and
and it can't be about convenience when
you know in essence you're saying you
know you have
a bunch of jewelry and you know you've
got
bandits that are basically walking
around your home
and you're not going to lock up your
jewelry because
you you may at any instant want to
change those you know big
earrings for you know set of your
diamond studs
right and that's again same thing
perfect way of doing it
and i think part of it is you know
i mean okay so look at security security
has had to grow up
we've literally had to make [ __ ] up as
we've gone along
because there haven't always been
solutions encryption is probably one of
the most defining ones
because you know i remember i mean when
we were dealing with encryption years
and years ago
it was kludgy it was complex getting
codes getting keys key rings keychains
on mainframe pgp
i remember pgp back in the late 90s
exactly i mean it was good but man it
was a pain in the asset and no
average normal user stood a chance of
dealing with it
but now when you fast forward we have
some amazing no password options you've
got fido alliances
out there you have things like true
certain you've got things you know
you've got you've got some of the other
stuff that i'm dealing with
with other teams in other organizations
that are out there that have
systems that will work at an enterprise
level added data arrest data in motion
data and transit all those other things
there's stuff there that will work
effectively
and especially these days much more
elegantly but it takes time it takes
effort and it takes money to put it into
place and
again if i come into an organization
and i argue with my auditor and go i
have a compensating control
i think i can do this i know i'm doing
this and the audit is like
the auditor wants to come back next year
you know they want to get a check in the
box and they want to come back next year
and they're the company browbeats as
opposed to going
as opposed to welcoming the auditor in
and going hey help me
understand what my problems are come in
as a
friendly and help me understand what's
going on
it's it's a much more adversarial
relationship and that's not how it
should be
so in in when in the companies you deal
with
you know what percentage would you say
or that way and what percentage are just
basically
um i got to go through this you know you
know
as soon as you can get out the better um
yeah
what does it look like what is the state
of play out there and say that in the
fortune 500
i i think so fortune 500 is interesting
i think there's a lot over the last
couple of years there's a lot of
companies have actually stepped up
um i the state stuff i just dealt with
the voting system i'm
really pleased with them because they
stepped up and they've been very very
proactive at going help us
understand and help us learn that's
refreshing but
i would argue there's still a decent
percentage in the fortune 500 that are
like
just just get it done and get the hell
out of here as quickly as you can and
give us our tick in the box
um and the argument for saying that is
if we if that
wasn't the case we wouldn't have we
wouldn't have as many high-profile
breaches as we do
as we still have so when you
so so we've been talking about what i
would
call kind of i don't know what version
you would call this but
talking about hacking of systems of data
systems of computers
you know now today what we have in
um in our modern system is hacking of
brains and you know what i'm talking
about there
is whether you're using you know the
algorithms of google
or or facebook or amazon to get you to
buy stuff or whether you're taking buy
to alibaba in 10 cent
in getting you to believe a narrative
you know
are you are do you work in those areas
are you primarily still confined to this
idea that i want to protect
um organizations from losing their data
and
and if you are if you are in kind of the
tick tock world
is what i'm talking about what um
what what advice would you have or kind
of what's your sense of where we're at
right now
you know vis-a-vis the rest of the world
just here in the united states
we're in poor shape i mean let's be
perfectly honest we are in really poor
shape i do spend a lot of time in that
world
actually ironically on linkedin this
past week
i just put an entire series out i took i
i did almost like a cartoon version
caricature version
and i put out five um social engineering
tabletop scenarios
and thirteen hundred characters in a
linkedin post and you gotta make it
really succinct
so i gave five very easy simple
scenarios that i've run across on a
regular basis where it's purely simply
human engineering
it's everything from you know me calling
up
i mean you think about it again go back
to the military world if your superior
calls you up and they are
hot and they are steaming and they're
pissed you're going to do whatever you
can to de-escalate that situation
and so in the civilian world we do the
same thing i'm going to be the ceo of
the company i'm hot and i'm steaming i'm
going to call up the accounting
department i'm pissed i'm going into a
meeting
i haven't seen the money yet it hasn't
been wide yet here's the account number
get this [ __ ] done now
and you wire the money and then the
following morning the ceo goes hey why
are we quoting a million dollars less
well i sent it to you and then that
whole wtf happens
and and i mean that's one of one of the
five scenarios i chucked out this week
and i'm actually going to keep it going
for the next several weeks because i
want people to start thinking
we at the human unfortunately has been
left behind
and it's not that the weakest link it's
not that we can't be trained it's not
any of those things it's simply that we
got ignored because whatever what
happened is everywhere our technology
will solve the problem
and we've realized technology can't
solve the problem we've forgotten about
the human
and we've forgotten about the processes
and we just concentrated on all the
blinky light stuff and so now we've had
to take a step back and go
how do we deal with the human how do we
educate them how do we train them
effectively
as well as how do we help protect them
in their personal life because that's
so bleeding into the work life i mean
it's now one life
especially with covet around us and
we have so much work to do so much work
to do that and we still want to train
them the old-fashioned way which is
another problem
you know we want to say we basically
want to look at them once every quarter
or once a year
and again you know this because i mean i
was training the national guard uh last
year and earlier this year as well
and i stood up in front of quite a lot
of folks and i'm like okay how many of
you go through awareness training in the
military and it was like oh yes
absolutely
i'm like okay how often do you go
through it or at least once a year
possibly once a quarter
i'm like so was it the same training
this year that you did last year do you
have the answers written down on the
poster and they're like
yes
how fast can i get through through this
computer-based training that's what i
remember
yeah and that's it and that's it we
don't
we don't train for the human we train
for the tick in the box and the audit
so that when tick tock comes along and
when all these other social media
when facebook asks you you know let me
tell you what your
cat character is by asking you these six
social engineering
questions we're like oh absolutely i was
born in this country and i did this
your cat character is a deep black
whatever the heck
character a cat from the the bronx you
know
and meanwhile somebody behind the scenes
is like yes i've got another
human information it's just we don't
think yeah my wife is totally wise to
all of those things so she
like you it is like it is hilarious if
somebody calls our house and tries to
get
you know personally forget about it it's
not going to happen you're not going to
get any person
for it if you're god you could be god
and you would not get any personal
information
sorry ain't going to happen moses you're
out
yeah that's it give me a call back
number click
[Laughter]
it's but i mean that's the challenge you
know you've grown up in that world i've
grown up in that world
in the us we have you know out of what
we got like 350 360 million
330 million people maybe
three four million maybe five million
are cynical enough to deal with this
stuff
almost ever actually no probably most of
the people in the midwest are cynical
enough to deal with it
and so many of the other people are just
sitting there they just they don't think
about it
it's an instant yeah okay i'll do this
and all of a sudden you realize you just
lost everything
let me give you a scenario because i i
want to know if this is something that
you think about too
because um it's something that i think
about
somebody asked me in the military
somebody who does acquisition asking me
about a company was a drone company
and they said you know what do you think
about this drone company and so i
googled the name and found it went on
linkedin and i found out that the their
their quality assurance engineer went to
jiaotong university so
so so i'm like well okay you have this
problem you know are these some of the
things that you think about as well or
is it
more you know more again isolated on
because
when you go to the point and there's so
much corollaries here right because
when we talk about aircraft accidents uh
or 90 are human error so you know
there's so much of the human involved in
understanding how do i secure my company
how do i secure my
my you know the crown jewels of what
were our intellectual property
and it's really not you know can i hire
x company
to put this you know exquisite security
system in in a lot of ways it's
it's the people that you hire to come
into the company so
you know that that's that scenario of
hey you know
i'm looking at on linkedin this person
comes from
china they're you know clearly their
families in china which means the
chinese communist party
has the ability to exert control over
them and yet they're in a key position
in my company
you know is that something that that
that that comes up in in what you're
working on and
and how does that usually play out when
you talk to if you do talk to
the companies that you do deal do
business with
yeah i mean it definitely comes out
because i mean it's you know you
mentioned china but i mean obviously
there's brain during going to other
other countries as well especially and i
mean we saw that play out fairly
recently in the news
where it was tesla you know one of the
individuals in tesla was offered
a decent chunk of change to plug in a
usb drive from somebody from you know
a foreign country in a foreign entity
and to their credit like
serious credit they actually said no
they didn't do it and they reported it
and they actually and they've been a
sting operation going with the agency
um that's huge and i mean i think again
it comes into a risk profile
you know we all we still think of risk
as digital risk we still think of risk
in the old days of did i lock my front
door
unfortunately what tends to happen is
when we bring people inside a company we
automatically assume that they're good
people
we've forgotten this whole problem about
insider trading about insider situations
you know again go back to the go back to
the first world and second world war you
know the whole loose lick sink
loose lips sink ships mentality is who
has to know needs to know and should
know right those are the only people
that need to know by the way
i know i can trust you because not only
but on the background but i know your
friends and your family i know where
they are know the influences on them
and therefore i'm okay with it because
i've done my due diligence
we don't do that so much and
unfortunately it's a tough one because
there is there's a balance because there
is some amazing technology coming out of
other countries that we do need to
leverage and we do need to work with but
we need to do it with open ice
you know i mean we've done it for years
we've done it for years with india and
we start looking at where all the data
where all the intellectual property is
going between those two countries
china being another perfect example you
look at stuff in germany the soviet york
russian lots of you
you look at those next to the woods and
go i'm happy to work with you i'm happy
to bring
you in and i'm happy to deal with the
projects but please understand as i do
this
just the thing that you would do with me
if i went to your country
i would want to do more due diligence i
would want to understand more what
potential risks i'm bringing in
that's you and i and we preach that to a
lot of the companies we deal with but
again so many people don't think that
way
yeah and so you you brought up something
here that just absolutely
infuriates me because you brought up the
tesla issue
tesla so that person fessed up
but there there is somebody that that
tesla has sued
for stealing their self-driving car data
by the way
also an apple engineer tried to do the
same thing
with their self driving car technology
the same company that is accused of
having people that bring that technology
to them x punk
xp eng i don't know if you've heard
about it just got a billion and a half
dollars on the new york stock exchange
in an ipo and i'm like
these guys are stealing technology and
in our and wall street is is ipo'ing
them
and that billion and a half dollars
doesn't go to the company goes to the
pboc
the people's bank of china this is you
know this is the problem with our
with our country right now that i see
and it really it pertains the entire
free world
yeah i'm no dispute on that one at all
in
any way shape or form i saw that and i'm
like congratulations we have just
rewarded the ability to steal other
people's ideas
um i mean it's i mean we know it happens
i mean i there was an amazing book that
was put out
10-15 years ago that was dealing with uh
effective intellectual property actually
using germany as a board
as a border organization and it was
amazing to see
the flow through europe then through
germany and then back out to china and
then back out to korea and various other
places and um absolutely amazing the
industrial asp.net went on even with
those organizations and again
it's again it's the human you know it's
back to you it's that data model
here's my crown jewels the only people
that should
need will do have access to it are those
that i
trust if that trust and validate or
validate trust and then by the way i'm
going to continue to validate the hell
out of you
okay so without revealing what i know
um i'm gonna i'm gonna ask you something
um
super micro you remember the story the
bloomberg
story
[Music]
this is this is a this is a good one um
so i have i have a an informed opinion
about that story but i would like to
hear
i would like to hear your version oh
that's an interesting one because i come
i come from even further back
which is years and years ago cisco
because cisco's maintenance and support
and equipment was pretty damn expensive
it's still expensive
people were buying gray markets cisco
equipment
that was being shipped over from china
and russia and they'd plug it in and it
would work beautifully and they'd pay
like 20 cents on the dollar for it
and they had a back-end vpn tunnel back
to those machines and it was in the same
same misspelled um you know in the
in the manuals misspellings
and so that was i remember backing i
remember dealing with some of that back
in those days
um and some of the issues around it then
you're right fast forward to the super
micro stuff
um oh that's a tough one because
again having worked with some of the
folks out of dc
i'm very well aware of what we can do
and what we're capable of doing
without tipping our hand and i think
that was the interesting one if you look
at sub diffusion deception
to me that was almost too obvious of
something that was going on
and it's that slighter found if i see
something over here i'm missing a lot of
stuff that's going on over here
and i think do i believe that we have
bud systems coming into this country
absolutely do i believe i mean
yes um do i believe that the journal and
some of the rpa people would have would
have found some of that stuff
if they did it was meant to be found as
opposed to the real stuff that hasn't
been found
well you know i think the backstory when
it finally comes out is
actually going to be even more
interesting than that
and um so uh you know i i do think that
was
probably um
i think it'll it'll go down and we're
gonna
i think the outcome of that is we're
going to question
really how we think of you know the
vulnerabilities
you know you know to our society
that exist in a cyber sense or in a
digital sense
versus in a physical sense because you
know in a lot of ways i think we
we tend to have this view and when i say
we
here i'm thinking loosely the
intelligence community
we have this view that if i find a
problem
i take note of it i don't do anything
though because it gives me an
opportunity to continue to observe and
this is
this is what i think is probably the
most egregious
it is as if um
you notice uh in your picket you know
and when i say
a picket you know in your in your
security you notice that
somebody has gone missing and there's a
gap in your security
and you want to watch to see who comes
in
rather than saying oh my god there's a
gap in our security
we better cover that up this is so
you know thoughts on it's oh i'm sure
you've run into this
idea oh i probably been part of that
problem in some ways because again it's
there's a couple of things on this one
and it's actually a really really good
point
perfect perfect way of putting it nsa
came out
a couple of weeks couple of months ago
and said hey we found vulnerabilities in
this and we're going to tell everybody
about it
the cynics among us were like well you
guys have probably known about this for
the last 10 years
and oh unfortunately now somebody else
says cotton don so you're just going to
get ahead of the news
and be nice people because let's face it
that probably is reality because we find
so many bugs and issues in systems and
quite honestly there is an ethical
conversation to happen
which is let's say i find a
vulnerability in and we'll talk about
these in a minute i found a
vulnerability in a phone
i can go to apple and say hey i've got a
vulnerability apple writes me a checkout
or i go to bug crowd or hack one
they write me a check out and i go off
on my merry way i can also take that
vulnerability
go to the u.s intelligence community and
say hey i've given you another
opportunity
to keep an eye on things because
potentially could save lives
there is that disgust now the problems
if i do that
the community at large are 330 million
people running around with these blasted
phones
don't get the benefit of getting better
coverage
flipside is i hopefully protect a bunch
of folks that are going in situation or
into theater
that otherwise would have compromised
the communication for it's a nasty
balance
and i think the micro thing was probably
one i mean
another example on this one fbi perfect
example fbi based in taran said
we need access we need to be able to
crack mobile phones
a lot of us in the industry were like
well go down go go ask the guys down the
road
from uh in the you know on the east
coast but they can't do that or even if
they can those agencies aren't going to
tip their hand
because you know darn well as soon as
you tell the fbi that this is on there
is going to end up in court at which
point we lose our advantage
and so they end up having to go over to
obviously israel and get it done that
way and it's just it's frustrating as
all
heck because it's like what do i want do
i want to protect the masses by
telling them and helping protect them or
do i want to protect the masses
by still being able to pull in
intelligence and information
because people don't realize how far
into their systems we actually are
yeah so i you know i think that i mean
this is really getting to the crux of
the
of the the of the problem and that is is
data security you know and data being
the
the the oil of the 21st century the
thing that drives artificial
intelligence and and big data and
machine
learning and all of that is that the
thing that we should be protecting
or do should we protect our prerogative
when it comes to having
access to other data so you know
the this is a classic military problem
do i
focus on the offense or do i focus on
the defense you know my
i've come to the conclusion that if we
don't focus on the defense in the united
states and by the way i think
the chinese and the russians have
figured this out
which is why the russians you know
basically
figured out that hey we need to be able
to disconnect from the global internet
and the chinese built a great firewall
we haven't figured this out and and i
think the authoritarians having to
control their society
were the first ones to recognize that if
we don't control this
if we don't as clinton said nail jello
to the wall
which he said they couldn't do and they
clearly have done then we're going to be
in big trouble in terms of controlling
our population so
it's really about understanding where
the 21st century is going in terms of
what is the biggest threat to your
society i think that's where we've
completely lost the bubble
and you know preserving our ability to
look into other systems
is not as important as protecting the
ability
for or preventing the ability of other
outside state actors
of looking into our system i think
that's
that's the key idea here if you go back
to for example and i'm gonna i'm gonna
go into a little bit of
cold war deterrence theory here yeah
an air force mathematician a guy named
lieutenant general glenn clanton
good book good monograph that he wrote
called thinking about defense and what
what he found was that in
1963 it would cost 28 billion dollars to
protect 70
of them of america from a nuclear attack
to create a defensive umbrella
but to protect 90 of the population
would cost six times that
the other thing that he found was that
for every dollar that this
that the soviet union added to their
icbm force
we would have to spend six dollars in
the in in defense
and so it was economically infeasible
and so i think
that's where mutually assured
destruction came from this is where this
idea came from
we're going to focus on growing our
economy our science and technology
and we're just going to tell the the the
the soviet union if you do anything it's
all out war
and so it was this deterrence theory
that kind of was our
our main theory uh of the
victory in the cold war but i think
today in the 21st century where
having your data is such an important
advantage
for artificial intelligence and and in
growing the
both the economy and your ability to
control populations
that the reverse is true you know we're
spending 800
billion dollars a year on defense and we
ought to be spending it
on protecting the data of our citizens
and i think that's where
i mean you're you're on the front lines
of that i mean would you would you
do you think do you agree with that
because you know that's where that's the
conclusion i've come to
uh it's it's hard to disagree with it
because you you hit two of the major
ones obviously
they are china's got the great firewall
and they have
a huge force level leveled against us i
mean absolutely in the digital world
they have a massive force level against
us i mean i don't know what the exact
ratios are but we're outnumbered quite
considerably
you look up to your point what russia
has done with the ability to disconnect
but then you take it come back to some
of our friends you look at what
a couple of countries in the nordic
world have done they have put
protections around their basically
borders and they put protections around
their citizens
you look at what israel has done israel
knows every single year is going to get
hit by up israel
and also all the countries around it are
doing everything on the physical and the
digital world to do everything they can
they have an entire section of that team
looking at protecting their internal
citizen their borders
we don't have that it's it's basically
all
it's you know we're all for ourselves at
this point in time it's it's the
mentality
is basically it's like hey you got your
second amendment you got your gun good
luck
by the way the second amendment is now
you've got your computer good luck
that's it you know i mean that's and and
that's not
going to work um and i think we should
spend
a now the challenge on that one is
the mentality of the us the population
of the u.s
is i want to look after myself don't you
dare take my guns don't you dare
threaten my bloody guns
don't do anything with my identity my
people or anything else
i can look after myself and i think we
have to convince people
in the physical world you got it covered
you can see him come in a mile away
in the digital world that's not the same
way
a very good friend of mine says we are
analog humans in a digital world and
i don't think so many people look that
way
feel that way or understand it we can't
see the enemy coming
in the digital world in the same way
that we can in the physical world so
we have to take a different tactic and
quite honestly
that data that we're trying to protect
there has to be somebody that takes a
step back and goes look we will take
care of it
the problem is those custodians of the
data at the moment are the googles are
the apples
are the microsoft of the world and let's
face it they're not there to protect us
they're there to make as much
money as they can and that's that's one
of my biggest problems yeah you know
when i talk about
the second amendment i think this is
such a good point because
if you think about the whole point of
the second amendment is to provide the
citizenry
the ability to resist an oppressive
government but
we have created a world now where you
can be oppressed without knowing who
your oppressor is or even
that you're being oppressed and so in
that world you know it's nice to have a
gun but you're
likely to be encouraged to kill your
neighbor because you think
your neighbor's enemy because you know
somebody else has convinced you of this
fact this is the problem that we have
today
and why i think it's so important for us
to focus on data security and
data sovereignty and really
understanding you know
what is the influences coming from
outside our borders and certainly how
social media and the whole e-commerce
environment is used to condition
our responses in ways that are quite
frankly
imperceptible to us well so i'll add
something onto your data security and
it's something we've noticed over the
last several years
and artificial intelligence is a huge
challenge when it comes to this
it's the integrity of that data so it
isn't just me breaking
and stealing the darn stuff and selling
it it's me breaking in
and changing that data effectively and
very subtly
in such a way that all of a sudden no
longer do you not like people who are
colored red
you don't like people who are colored
green either because i've changed the
metrics i've changed the subtleties
i've influenced that data without
actually doing it without disrupting it
and to your point we're seeing it
with social media we're seeing it with
disinformation campaigns we're seeing it
with
everything i mean microsoft just
released something last couple of days
they finally announced it
and there's actually a couple of
companies over in israel doing something
similar
where they are specifically hunting for
disinformation
you know links sites people urls all
sorts of stuff i mean there's
a ton of that out there and it's to me
it's the integrity of that data as well
that comes into play right
that's a good point and i think so if
you think about this in a just as in a
use case example i'll use the military
so you have an algorithm uh that is
looking for
the enemy tanks and you condition that
data so that as that
algorithm is being developed as that
learning is taking place
there are holes in it so that you know
it when it
when it does come to your tank it's not
identified i mean that's one example of
you know i think that's what you're
getting at is what does the algorithm do
what you intended it to do
well if the data has has anomalies in it
then that algorithm may in certain cases
not
do what it was intended to do totally
well the other thing is as well i mean
you and i have i
i i spent time in foreign countries
getting shot at let's face it
i knew who was shooting at me i was very
well aware of who
i was very well aware of what they were
shooting at me with
i saw it coming i knew what was going on
and if i didn't we had enough time to
get cover
we don't have that in the digital world
i can't do
attribution i don't know whose hand or
whose fingers are on that damn trigger
let alone why and let alone the
motivation everything else this is one
of the biggest challenges i see
we have a lot of people who stand up and
go hey we need to
we need to hack back i'm like don't do
that [ __ ] you're gonna
basically hack some poor grandma's
computer in north korea because well
that's where we're all congregating
because it's fun to blame them every
five minutes
um and i think that's the biggest
problem is we we in the digital world
have a
much uh a much harder time figuring out
who our enemy actually is or even where
they're coming from half the time and
that's that's a bit of a challenge
yeah and something that we need to work
on well chris this has been a fantastic
conversation i hope you enjoyed it i
really have enjoyed it i've enjoyed it
having you on hope to have you on again
thanks for being
on generally speaking i really uh i
really admire your work and uh
and we need more people like you you
know we have you know
a lot of people um shooting guns and and
driving planes like i used to do
but we need a lot more that are
defending our digital spaces
working on it thank you absolute honor
and a pleasure to be on thank you very
very much
much appreciated thank you
you